Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today, I’m
going to explain a science fiction
thriller film called “Children Of Men.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
The premise of the movie is set in 2027.
Female fertility has become non-existent
for the past eighteen years, and doctors are lost
to explain the reason. With no women reproducing,
humankind has not had a new child born in eighteen
years, and the world is falling apart. Most of
the world's societies have collapsed due to
war and paranoia of extinction of humans;
African and East European countries collapse,
and the people migrate to other wealthy nations.
The UK has become a police state because of the
increase in the number of illegal immigrants,
and the police have the authority
to arrest any they find.
At the beginning of the movie, we see
the news the world's youngest citizen,
Argentine Baby Diego, who was eighteen years
old had died. He was murdered by an angry fan
when he refused to give them an autograph.
The newscast is watched by a saddened and stunned
crowd in a Fleet Street coffee shop; humankind is
facing the likelihood of its own extinction. A man
named Theo Faron enters the coffee shop, seemingly
indifferent to the news story or the crowd.
Just after he leaves and stops to add liquor to
his coffee, the shop is blown up by a bomb.
The act is attributed to an underground guerrilla
group, the Fishes. Theo is shaken by the incident
and leaves work early, under the excuse
of being shaken by Baby Diego's death.
He instead visits his friend, Jasper. The two
drive to a well-hidden forest home, where Japer
lives with his catatonic wife, Janice. They live
a secluded life and grow cannabis in the place.
The following day, while walking to work,
Theo is kidnapped by two men who put him in
a van and drive off. The people reveal that
they are an organization called the fishes,
who protest against the British government to
provide equal rights to every immigrant.
It turns out the group is led by Theo’s ex-wife,
Julian. Julian and Theo had a son named Dylan,
who died in a flu pandemic twenty years ago,
the two had not seen each other since. She first
tells him that the Fishes were not responsible
for the bombing of the cafe the previous day;
then one of her group angrily claims
that the government bombed the cafe,
trying to create discontent for the Fishes.
Julian wants Theo to make fake transit papers
for an illegal immigrant, with the help of
his cousin who works in a government sector.
Theo visits his cousin and is able to get the
papers, but they specifically state that Theo
himself must accompany this immigrant out of the
city. He agrees and he with Julian, her associate
Luke, the immigrant Kee, and her midwife Miriam
drives to the southern coast of England together.
On their way, they are stopped by a car
in flames in the middle of the road.
Soon, a large mob of people attacks them.
Everyone panics, and Luke starts to drive
the car in reverse. However, a person
in front of them shoots Julian dead.
As they flee the scene of the attack,
they are pulled over by the police.
When asked for their papers, Luke kills both
policemen. A short funeral is held in the forest
for Julian. Theo breaks off temporarily from the
service and cries privately for Julian. Luke is
able to find another car and drives them to a
safe house on a farm where the Fishes gather.
Theo tells Kee that he is going to leave, and
the fishes can take care of her. However, she
starts to take off her clothes. Theo is stunned
when he sees that Kee is eight months pregnant.
Everyone in the fishes knows this and claims
that it is a miracle. The group then discuss
what should be their next move, and Theo insists
they should make the pregnancy public. However,
the fishes claim that the British government would
take Kee and her child away and use them for their
own benefit. They leave the decision to Kee, who
agrees to stay in the custody of the Fishes.
At night, Luke wakes up to a commotion outside,
and sneaks out to see two injured men arrive
at the house. One of them is Julian’s
associate and a sociopath named Patric.
He eavesdrops on Luke and Patric’s conversation,
and is horrified to figure out that Julian’s
murder and the riot were all planned by the
fishes. They want to use Kee’s baby for their
own needs, presumably to make money off her.
Moreover, they plan to kill Theo the following
day. After hearing all this, Theo panics.
He quickly goes into Kee’s and Miriam’s room and
tells them that Luke was behind Julian’s death.
Before her death, Julian had told Kee to trust
Theo before everyone, so she believes him. He
takes the two women and sneaks out of the house.
Theo disables all of their other cars, gets the
women inside a car, and narrowly escapes them.
Theo then takes them to Jasper's house since it
is hidden and secluded. Arriving there, Jasper
is surprised to see Kee pregnant, and agrees to
help them. He makes arrangements for Kee to meet
a ship called the Tomorrow, a vessel belonging to
a group called the Human Project, a collection of
scientists based in the Azores off Portugal, and
dedicated to restoring human fertility. They are
the only people that will help Kee genuinely. The
following morning, the fishes somehow manage to
find Jasper's home. This sets of an alarm and
alerts them. Theo quickly gets everyone in the
car to take them to Jasper’s friend, Syd, who will
help them get to the Tomorrow ship in a boat.
Theo, Kee, and Miriam watch the fishes get to
Jasper from afar. When Jasper refuses to talk,
they shoot him dead. Theo is frustrated and
saddened by his friend’s death, but gets inside
the car and continues the mission anyway. The
three reach an abandoned school, and stay there
until a car arrives in the compound. Inside the
car is Jasper’s friend, Syd, who happens to be
an immigration officer. The plan is to get the
three arrested as immigrants and send them to the
tomorrow ship in the immigrant bus. Syd takes them
to a refugee camp, where they see the military
killing the refugees one after another. Throughout
the way, Kee goes through contractions and
whimpers in pain. Miriam, who was a gynecologist
before the infertility pandemic, helps Kee with
the contractions. They successfully manage to
get on the refugee bus and head toward Bexhill.
On the way, Kee’s water breaks, and she is about
to give birth. An immigrant officer comes inside
the bus and asks what is wrong with her. Miriam
acts strange to get the officer’s attention off
Kee. She is arrested and taken off the bus, while
Kee and Theo reach Bexhill without detection.
There, the two meet a woman named Marichka, who
takes them to an old rusty room for the night.
As soon as they get inside, Kee’s contraction
gets worse and she starts giving birth.
Theo helps her with it, and within some time,
she gives birth to a beautiful little girl.
The two happily celebrate.
The following morning, they wake
up to Syd and Marichka banging on the door. They
tell them that the Fishes have broken into the
city and the national guard have been called
out to restore order. Outside, several riots
and shootouts are taking place. Kee tries to hide
her child from them, but they eventually see her.
Marichka tries to tell Theo and Kee to not
go with Syd because he is a bad person,
but Syd threatens them with a gun. As it
turns out, Syd wants to turn Theo and Kee
in for money. Marichka attacks Syd and the three
narrowly escape. Amidst the riots and shootouts
in the street, they manage to get to Marichka’s
family. They take great care of the baby and Kee,
and agree to help them to get to a boat.
They put Kee in a wheelchair and run outside.
The streets are in chaos, bullets fly
everywhere as they make their way to the boat.
But before they get there, the fishes take Kee
away from them and kill Marichka‘s associate.
However, the fishes are attacked by the British
forces, and Marichka and Theo manage to flee.
They run amidst the shootouts and bomb
explosions, and are soon separated.
Theo goes around the buildings, looking for Kee
and the child. He then goes upstairs and finds
Kee with her crying baby, hiding in a corner
amongst other dead and injured people.
Luke is on the other side, shooting
at the force from the window.
As Theo attempts to take Kee and the baby
out, Luke opens fire in Theo's direction,
but Luke is killed a few moments
later, and they manage to escape.
As they come out of the room, it explodes. The
two finally get out of the place with the baby,
as everyone who sees them is stunned. The shooting
and explosions stop, as the people watch the baby
in awe. A soldier orders everyone to cease
the firing, some of them get down on their
knees to pray. As the two get away, the shooting
starts again but they manage to flee and reunite
with Marichka. Theo, Kee, and the baby get
into the boat and finally leave the harbor.
They see fighter jets flying overhead, and Kee
is worried that they are late. Theo assures her
that they will get to the tomorrow ship.
Kee sees blood and starts to freak out,
claiming that she is bleeding, but Theo says that
it is his, as it turns out that Luke had shot Theo
before they ran away. An injured Theo teaches
Kee to burp her baby. As he whimpers in pain,
Kee tells him that she will name her
baby Dylan, after Theo’s late son.
Theo soon loses consciousness, as Kee
looks around and calls his name helplessly.
Just then, her face is lightened up to
see the tomorrow ship in front of them.
They have finally reached their
destination. Before the movie ends,
we hear the sound of children laughing, suggesting
that the world has gone back to how it was.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on notifications, and leave a
like to help the channel out.
Thank you for watching.